Yes, we would have, we would have had a
whole conversation.
It's been 30 minutes.
We're like, "Hey,
should we record this
conversation?"
Um, I think I have a
resume recording from AI.
OK.  So, this is
an interview with Alan
Dro and Brian
Kurtz.  Um, I...one of
my premises is also that
I
see myself as a bridge between,
you know, because a lot of
people who, you know,
grew up even in, in...
the direct marketing of the '
80s and '90s.  Um,
many of them are
no longer around, or they
can't tell
that story.  And I also
made the transition from
offline to online
because I was an
online student.  Actually, you
know, that's why I don't
give up
podcasts.  I don't
turn down
interviews, especially with,
you know, younger,
more dynamic
marketers than
myself, because I really want to
learn from them.  And so
I mean, you
know, I'm in
masterminds, where, you
know, I'm usually
one of the oldest in
every group I'm a member of
, and I get in
there for the "golden
ticket" because they
think I
know something, and that's an advantage.
So they tell me, "Oh
yeah, you can
join, Brian."
That's good.  Even if
you have no idea what you
're talking about when it
comes to
online [ __ ].  But I
can also be
dangerous in some
online areas, but
I know my limits
.  I know what I don't
know.  Well, I don't know what I do
n't know,
but I also know what
I don't know.  And so I am a
teacher, but I am also a
student.  And this brings
us back to Breakthrough
Advertising.  I was a student of
Gene Schwartz and,
you know, many
other big names in
marketing.  I want to
continue this
trend.  But you
can't be a teacher
without
constantly learning.  So that
was always my
premise.  So I'm
like a bridge connecting
all of this with everything that's
modern today.  It's not that
I'm doing
anything cutting-edge myself, but
I know what it is.  And I
invite the
most modern
specialists to my
mastermind to
speak.  And I
know, I know what I don't
know.  You know, I know
what I know, and I know
what I don't know.  And so, why
not, you can't
be an
expert in everything.
So why not, you know,
bring in the experts?
It's like a tyrannosaurus
, and you know that's
where it all
starts.
I think that's great
, and it's actually a
perfect transition to what
we're
talking about today
, because that's what
prompted me to
reach out to Chris
Mason, our
mutual acquaintance.
Yes.
True.  I reached out to
Chris because in my era of
copywriting—I'm 32,
so I'm not the youngest,
but I'm not the oldest
in this game, right?
I still have a lot to
learn.  But what's
happening in my era of copywriting is that
everyone
is in the
golden age of AI right now,
you know?  The Golden
Age of AI.  I look
around and I see all
my friends, my
competitors—or whatever you
call them—"
coexistence of
competition," as you
like to teach, right?  In
that sense, I see
everyone selling AI
prompts and
things like that.  And over the last
six months, I've been
really tempted to
go back to thinking,
"Man, I need to
go through this
book again."  I need to
dive into this, because
right now, I think
fundamentals are a lost
art.
Yes.  No.  And it becomes kind of a
differentiator,
you know, like direct
mail is a
differentiator,
because nobody...you know
, some young
marketers are asking,
"Direct mail, what is it, a
new media channel?"
You know, it's like...and that's
normal.  This is
normal.  But, again
, direct mail
today
is different from what
it used
to be.  I mean,
you can't
do the kind of mailings
I did at Boardroom anymore.  They
simply do not exist.
You know, mailing 9
million
copies of a
single book for
$39 is impossible right now
.  You won't
find 9 million
mailing addresses
that would generate
any profit.  On
the other hand, direct
mail on the backend of any
online business
is a differentiator.  And
the irony is that I...I'm
in
Jeff Walker's master class.  Do you
know Jeff Walker?
Oh, cool.  Yes, I know
Jeff Walker through
Chris Orzikowski.
Repeat again.
I know Jeff Walker
through Chris
Orzikowski, he's
my husband.
Chris Orzikowski,
right?
And yes, I saw Chris
promoting PLF.
Yes, he did.
Yes.  So, um, I,
I was invited to
Jeff
Walker's mastermind as a
guest speaker.
Good.
What surprised me.  I
mean, it was, it
was a great story.    I
think I
told it on the blog
.  Perhaps.  I think I
also told it in
my book in
Chapter 10, where Jeff
Walker sent a request
on LinkedIn and said,
you know, um, you know, is this the
same Brian
Kurtz?  And I sent
him an
email response.  I
asked, "Is this the
same Jeff Walker?"  And
we knew each other
before.  We may have
even met,
but we weren't particularly
close.  And we started
communicating via email
.
I think we probably
talked on
the phone.  Um, Zoom
wasn't popular back then.
That was about 11
years ago.  Um, and he
said, "Why do
n't you come to my
mastermind? You'll
come, give a
presentation,
talk to my
wonderful online
marketers at PLF."  And I didn't
go anymore because
I came there as a
speaker.  Um, I, I, it
was like a
love group, you know, I
love them, they
love me, and I
just joined.  I
always said it was a
trick by Jeff to
get
$25,000 a year from me
for 12 years.  Um,
so this is a running joke
, but it's incredible.  I
mean,
being in that
group was one of the
gifts of my
career.
I mean, I'm talking
about, you know, you're
talking about, you know,
Stu McLaren and, um, I
can't even
list all the
amazing
marketers that
were a part of, you know
, Jeff Walker,
Ryan Lee.  I
mean, so many.  Eh,
Will Hamilton,
amazing, amazing
marketers.  And I
got there because of a
technicality.  I
mean, if I, if
I applied, if
Jeff didn't know me, and
I would have applied for
his mastermind
when I joined, which
was probably in 2012.
May, uh, what, what
year is it now?  2025th.
2025th.
Yes, probably 2013,
maybe.  Anyway
, if I
applied, I would be
rejected, you know.
But.
Why, why do you
think that?  Because I'm not,
he was mostly,
he, and this is my own
perception, maybe
I would have been turned down
because I didn't do
launches,
traditional launches
.
Good.  It's interesting that when
I first
got there, it could be
attributed to Gene
Schwartz and others, but
I think by the time
I got there, he was
just starting to bring in
other people, not
generalists, but
specialists from other
areas of marketing,
public figures who were
doing something other
than just launching
online products.
Two of them, one
was Victoria Lab.
Victoria Lab is an
amazing public
speaker.  She teaches
the art of performance.
She works with
corporate
executives.  And Annie
Gaiman Pratt, who is an
organization expert, changed
all the companies in
Jeff's group because
she taught them how to build a
business, not just a
product or a promotion.
You know, building a
real business with
structure,
employees, and
ways to make a
profit, because
most of the people in
Jeff's group were
originally living from
startup to startup.
It was like this: if one
of your two or three
launches a year
fails,
your business suffers
all year long.
So yes.
And so, when I first
came there as a
speaker, I saw them and
said, "Oh, it's not just the
launch guys here."  Maybe,
but if I had
applied when he
first
offered it, I wouldn't have
met his
criteria.  Certainly.
That's interesting, because I
think in the book
Overdeliver you mentioned
that you were part of six or
eight
masterminds.
Over time.  Not all at
the same time, though.
Of course.
Yes.  And over time, I
participated in different
groups.  I don't pay for some
.  I
pay a lot for some.  Some of
them aren't even
masterminds, but
coaching groups or
something like that.  But yes,
I tried to
calculate.  Over the course of my
career, I have spent
over a million
dollars on
masterminds,
including all
travel and related
expenses.
Well over a
million dollars for
my education.  Although this
is my education.  I consider
this the tuition fee
to become a true
direct
response marketer.
Yes.  Yes.  Oh,
in addition to all
those basics I knew
from the beginning,
starting with Gene
Schwartz.
Yes, this will be the thesis
for promoting this
material.  How much did
Brian Kurtz pay to
learn the art of
direct response?  I
like it.  We will
use it.  But
a lot of that
and the fact that the bootcamp
only costs 297 indicates
that
something like this can be done.
You can do 297 to
a million, or 297 to a
mastermind for
$25,000, and you'll
get more in
two weeks.  I give you
the text, but you are the
copywriter.  But
I will make the anchor price
a million.
Yes, set the price
at a million,
right?  Ahem.
This is great.
But you know, you
can fit
six 90-
minute calls into two weeks.
It's like a mini-
mastermind of epic
proportions, right?
I did so.  That's the
first thing I said
when I
was talking to
Chris a few weeks ago, I was taking
notes.  I said, "
Hey, send me the
landing page."  And
he sent me the
landing page.  I
said, "Hey, the price
is wrong. You
missed a unit
before the price, or a
few units before
the bootcamp."  And he says
: "No, this is the price."  And I
said, "But the book
costs 120. Are you
sure?"
Yes.  And he says,
the first time we did a
bootcamp,
it cost 99.
I think that's
crazy.
But the thing is, my
business was
built on a
price-cutting model,
meaning when I left
Boardroom, the first
product I
launched
was a
$20,000 mastermind.
Because I had 34 years of
connections and
relationship capital.  So I was able to
attract, I immediately
sold 23 companies to
my mastermind
in a few weeks.  So,
yes, do
the math yourself.  That's
$400,000.  This is a
40% margin business, right?
So I did that, and
then I stopped it
at the 30-
company mark,
some of which also
had partners.  So I
froze my
mastermind.  But I
had up to 45 participants, each with
20 or 25 thousand.  This is a
business in itself.  Not
counting Gene
Schwartz and Breakthrough
Advertising, not
counting the other
things I was
doing.  So it was all
going from there, it was all going
downhill from there,
as opposed to
me not starting with a
$99 product
to get to a $
25,000 mastermind.
So, about the low
check: I wasn't too
worried about it because it was
like a nice
add-on, and I wanted to
reach more people.
So there was a method to this madness
.  I
deliberately set a
low price.  My
mastermind, Titans
Accelerator, which costs 2000
per year, is completely
undervalued, but I
want to involve
as many people as possible
to reach a wider
audience and
spread knowledge, as
well as gain
experience from them.  And I
found out that for
many young
marketers, 2000 is a
big amount.
Yes.
So,
yes, you're not wrong.
And that's actually why we're
talking today, because I
feel the same way,
except you've had the opportunity
to spend time with
people like
Gene.  You've actually
talked to
legends, Benga,
Deutsch—all these guys, and
I'm putting together a
copywriter mailing list and I
keep getting
people asking,
"Who is this?" and I'm like, "Are
you serious?"  Have
n't you looked into
this?  Who are you reading?
Who do you listen to?  And it's
really an advantage that
I had contact with
each of them.  I mean,
I literally touched
them.  I hugged
most of them.  But it's
interesting that once at a
conference I was
approached by a Gene
Schwartz fan, a young
guy who
learned about Gene
after his death
.  Which fascinates me too
.  The fact that you are now becoming a
Gene Schwartz fan
just
by talking to
me gives me
great pleasure.
You know, you're a new
fan, but you'll be one
for life, and of
course.
But I was at a
conference, and a
32-year-old
guy came up and said, "
You know, I heard you
touched Gene
Schwartz."  I replied: "
Yes."  I said I
even hugged him
a few times.
Brian, you give me
reasons to talk.
You are just that.  This is
incredible.    I mean
, besides
you making out with Gene
Schwartz, I heard you
actually went to
his penthouse.
Yes.
And discussed
commerce, advertising
letters, when you
worked in the Boardroom.
Tell me about it.
Yes.  So, essentially,
Gene Schwartz and Marty
Edelston, the founder of
Boardroom, were
buddies.  They
had known each other
since Marty's days
when he was selling, um,
advertising space,
direct
response advertising in magazines and
such.
So he met
all
the copywriters.  Marty
himself was a great
communicator.  And
so he met Gene
, and they became friends
.  I think Jin Gan
wrote an ad
for a Jewish
encyclopedia that
Marty found and it
captivated him.  He
thought it was the
most amazing
text and sought out
Gene.  I don't know exactly
how they
met, but it
was something like that.  And so
, um, Gene was writing
lyrics for us, and we could
—I know, one of
your questions was about
writing lyrics
for names.  Um, yeah, but
...
He wrote lyrics for us
, and look, I
was in the
marketing department.  I
met
Gene when he
came to the office and
all that.
And, you know, he
liked me.  I
treated him well too.
It wasn't a close
relationship at first.
I was like a little student,
you know.  I was like, I was
like a guy, well, a
marketing
guy.  Not even a
marketing director.  I was a
marketing
guy.  And...
Were you still the
list manager at that time
?  You just listened.
When I met him, I
was, or I was...no, I had
already started...
actually, I
was probably already the
marketing director at that time
, but I was
using all
my
list management knowledge
to be the
director, because I was
essentially reviewing our
mailings and working
with the lists the same way I was
when I was selling the
Boardroom lists, because it's the same thing
.  It's
like, um, you know, what
kind of promotions
attracted that name.  I
always looked at the
lists that way because we
had the best
copywriters, you know;
and so I knew that our
lists were great
because of the copywriters
who created them—
whether it was Gene, or Mel
Martin, or Ben Swana.
appeared a little
later, but he
was there.  And the lyrics were
so impulsive
.  Continuous intrigues,
shootouts, all that.  And the
type of people who would
respond to such
an offer, knowing
that we are targeting
executives, people
who are already wealthy, and
now they are also
mail-
order junkies.  It's like all
they want is to
buy more
through direct
mail.
You could see why
Boardroom lists were,
you know, a real
gem of the
list industry.  So when I
moved into marketing,
I analyzed every
list I sent
emails to.  Any
list that
my brokers gave me.
I had—I even
blogged about it
.  It was a "
guilty until
proven guilty" approach
.  And I developed a
worksheet where my brokers
— I was a very
demanding client
for them.  I told them: you
have to fill out
this sheet for each
list you
recommend.  And
one of the requirements was
to add a sample
advertising letter,
which was used to
collect the database of names on
this list.  This
gave me more
information than
anything else to
understand whether I could
link it to a
promotion.  I could,
for example, know that
Agora uses the
same copywriters.
Phyllis Publishing
used the
same copywriters.
If I saw a
Phyllis Publishing list
using a
package from Gary Benga
or Jim Roots, I
knew that list would be a
hit for Boardroom
.
You know, Agora
was much
smaller at that time.  It wasn't a
billion-
dollar business then, but I knew them
from the beginning.
Bill Bonner was also
one of my early
mentors.  And I
knew Mark
Ford very well.
Oh, yes.  Agora and Boardroom have
always been very,
very close.  We
were so
close that
we exchanged so
many names that
when we did the
merging and cleaning of
mailing lists,
I got 40%
duplicates.  I mean, we
were...Wow.
Yes, it was, but
again, you
come out with a different
promotion, and I have a
whole story about
how Bill Bonner
imitated one of
our packages but
couldn't get the
same result, even though the
lists were the same
.  You think
not.  There's a "gestalt" of a
mailing list that
depends on the list,
on everything—there are so
many factors.  This is
not based on
one factor, but the
overlap in the lists was
very large.  So
the idea was...
what connected me to
Gene was
amazing, because I was
just
talking to him in
the office, I remember,
and he had
a little book
company called Instant Improvement
, "sexology for
two" and how to get rid of your
belly, and all that
[ __ ].  I mean,
yeah.  Yes.
Aha.  The content wasn't
great.  The promotions were
incredible.  I
mean, just a
role model.  And
so we're talking, and
I say, "Do you know what
lists you send to
besides Boardroom and Rodale?"  And
he says, "You know, my
listing broker
does this."  I knew
his broker from the
listings.  Don't
put that in...even though
I'm sure that
guy is dead now,
but he was [ __ ].  And
his company
was like that too, but it was
his broker.  So I
said, "Gene, let me
take a look at the
list plans that they're
putting together for you, I'll
make sure you're
getting everything you
need, because you have to
send to all those
health lists that
we send to, because
we had health products too
."
And he gave me lists.
I remember he gave
me a list of plans.
Some of them
weren't even close, even though they should
all have been there.
And the lists they
were sending to didn't
have the right
samples.  So there were
specific points,
like on the Rodale list,
even Rodale had to
take certain
segments depending on
their
promotion patterns.  If they've
been sending out, say, a
women's book in the
last six
months, you
don't need those names.
You need the names of
people who bought a
men's book six
months ago, even
without considering
novelty.  These are the
subtleties of sampling,
so I simply
reworked
Gene's list plan.  I
certainly wasn't going to
take money from him
or anything like that.  And it
was...I did it without
any expectations.
I just wanted to do it
.  Well, damn it
, Gene Schwartz,
you understand.
And I remember him saying that
.  And then he
made mailings.  They
worked much
better, of course.  I
mean, I didn't
do the mailing itself,
but I provided him with the
best
list picks.
And so he He
...we...he just...
I always say: you don't
choose your
mentors, your
mentors choose
you.  And he chose me as
his protégé,
basically because I, you
know, I just...I
just exceeded
expectations because,
first of all, I love this
guy.  He was, you know, a
wonderful man,
warm, uh, gentle,
uh, had a hot
temper.  You know,
if Marty didn't
agree with one
of his headlines,
he would get...he would
get annoyed, uh.
He was protective of his
job
, he was very
protective of his job,
uh, but he...he
befriended
me.  So then,
you know, I would come to
his house, a few
times, maybe, I don't
know, maybe not
every month, but, you know,
I would come there, and we would have
dinner in his
big dining room.  He,
he was, he was a
big
collector of
modern art,
and he had a lot of
stuff in his warehouse and in his
penthouse, everywhere.  And
so every time
I came there,
it was a different collection
, because he would take the
paintings out after 6
months and bring back a
different set of paintings.  And
he opened, he and
his wife Barbara,
who is still alive and
receives royalties from
Breakthrough Advertising.
They were both, uh,
incredible
art collectors, and they
discovered a lot of
young artists
who are now
famous contemporary
artists.  And actually,
I wrote about it somewhere,
but in Gene's obituary
, uh, in the New York
Times, it was a long
obituary, and it was
dedicated to his
art collecting prowess.  There's just
one paragraph about,
oh, he had a
book publishing house and
wrote advertising
copy.
Seriously?  This is
amazing.
Yes.  So I spent, I
spent a lot of
quality time with him,
you know, studying.  I
mean, he, he
was really
instructive.  He, one
of the, one of the great phrases
, uh, that I used a lot
, he
said to me, uh, I
remember giving him a
big medical
encyclopedia that
we had and saying, "
You know, Gene, you're
going to write a proposal
for this."  And his
first question, his
first question
was always, "What's not in
this book?"  what is
not in the newsletter.
And by what he
was trying to do,
he was trying
to spark additional
curiosity in both me and
our
editors.
So, uh, I'll fast
forward, because the best
copywriters
today do the same thing
.
Parisopropolis, I
told this
story on the blog.
Parasopropolis was doing a
proposal for my
natural
healing newsletter, and I
said, "Can you
do a proposal
for that?"  He
read past
issues.  He
looked at the
controlling interest,
whoever wrote it, and
said, “I don’t want to
write for this.  "There's
nothing
interesting here."  And I said,
“Yeah, nothing
cutting edge.  "It's all the
same [ __ ]."
And I said, he doesn't
want to, you know, Paris
can only be
as good
as the
content is good.  Although sometimes
you can make your
charms better than the
content itself.
Whatever it is that you
need on the plane, it's
much better than an
answer,
you know.  Yes,
that's normal, because you have to
intrigue people somehow.
So he and I came up with
this idea.  Paris
said, “Let me
talk to
the editor of the newsletter
about natural
healing,”
and he met with him,
and essentially his
only question was,
“What aren’t you adding
to the newsletter?  The same as
Gene would say: "
What's not in the book?"
And the editor had a bunch of
articles that were from
gurus.  We had a guru in
this newsletter, a doctor, a
naturopathic doctor.
And he had a lot of
articles about cutting-edge
treatments and
the latest things that
our editors
rejected because they
were very
conservative,
our editors.  So
we got to the heart of the
problem.  Now,
was some of
the information still
contradictory?  Yes.  I
mean,
urine therapy is
controversial.  Even at
that time,
chelation therapy was
very controversial.
But Paris encouraged them
to find more
evidence for some of
this research so I
could use it in the
package.  And he
pushed them.  It
was impossible
to stop.  We are not
going to lie.
We are not going to
lie in
the text, but find
me materials that
can confirm
this.  And they got
a lot of new
material, and that
always became
the headline in his
package or in his
advertising letter
because it
was always the most cutting-edge and the
most interesting to
write about.  And I think
that's...I don't know if
Gene invented it, but
I got it from
Gene.  And I think
Paris has this
amazing, I don't know,
he just has this
sixth sense, and he
has, he has, he has the
lyrics, he has this gene
, you know?  If there is a
copywriting gene,
Paris has it.  And
a lot of it is his
curiosity, his
inquisitiveness, and his "
never, never
settle for the first
answer," all of that
because the best
copywriters are the
best interviewers,
always.
And
so.
So, I mean,
I learned a lot
from Gene in
those meetings.  But
also, every time I
saw him work,
how he wrote his
stuff, it was...I
mean, a
little note
that just shows
his dedication to the
cause and how he
never gave up.
Um, maybe you know
, but he had a
serious stroke,
after which he...
Yes.  Yes.  If you
saw the recording with
Rodell, you would have
noticed that his
right hand
was still the entire time.  He
gestured with only
one hand.
And that's why
he wrote
one particular
sales letter, right?
He wrote one text
for free
because that guy
helped him
recover from a
stroke.  He said
that he helped
restore mobility
to my right arm, which is
...
Interesting, I haven't heard that
story.
Yes, mobility has
not
fully returned.  He could
lift her.  But when he
shook my hand, it was
like squeezing a sponge.
Ahem.
Oh,
yes.  Well, you know.
He had little
sensation in his right
hand.  The point is that
he ended up typing
on a mechanical
typewriter with
one finger.  That's
why a mechanical
typewriter
is depicted on
the cover of "
Breakthrough Advertising."
A.
Because he typed with
one finger.  He
searched and tapped the
keys on that
QWERTY keyboard with
virtually one
finger, and he
wrote a huge
amount of text
that way.
Oh my God.  Now,
of course, he's definitely
talking about this when
...it seems like it was
his speech at
Phillips, where he
broke it up into three
33-minute sessions.
He did this three times.
Right.  Right.
Pomodoro method.
Yes.  Is this called the
Pomodoro method?
timer for 33 minutes.
Maybe it's him.
Maybe so.  But in
this we see such a
feature of Jin.
He obviously
created tons of
texts.  You spent
a lot of time with him.
Was he always in
deep
work mode, or perhaps
he had an
art collection?
Yes.  No, he was a very,
he was a very
versatile person.
When he talked about
business, he talked
about business, but no,
he was very
versatile.  He
loved baseball.  We didn't get
too deep
into baseball, but, well, he
was...
he was, he was
focused all the
time, but that was one
of the things that
made him a great
copywriter.  There's a
quote in one of
my blogs, you know,
it's about, it's about,
you know, about art
and what's going on
in the world.  There's also another
quote, you know, if
you don't spend time
with your market, you're
done.  Actually, if
you don't spend time
being in the world,
in your... I
mean, John Carleton
talks about this when
he talks about,
you know, being attentive
to everything around you,
rather than, you know, some people
think that to write
, you have to put on
headphones,
turn off all the noise,
sit in a dark
room and write or
sit in a bright
room and write.  And
he did it differently.
He always, I
mean, his favorite
magazine was the National
Enquirer because he
really, he really
wanted to see what
made this country
work,
you know, what made
people vibrate.
Marty often
used
the term "I want
your text to vibrate."
Um, and he knew what
made people
vibrate in the
sense of what, what were
people talking about?  What
interests them is not to
write about
current events in the
newsletter.  He didn't do
it often because it
was dangerous in
direct mail
, because you write a
package and it doesn't come out
for six or
nine months, or
at least 6 months,
maybe even
four.  But current
events are changing
very quickly.  They are
no longer current.  But
he just wanted
to understand what
people are thinking, and he
says: know what
your market is thinking all the
time.  And that was
part of his
writing ability.  Ahem.  It was, um
, the Pomodoro technique, by the
way.  Ahem.  this, and, and this,
you know, the basic, and he was
doing it with 33
minutes, 33
seconds, but you
can do it with 10
minutes, it doesn't matter,
but you have to, it's
basically, you know,
intensity,
relaxation,
relaxation.  And
during relaxation, you
walk, but he walked
outside.  He went outside
for a walk.
He, you know, he wanted to
, he was an
observer of
culture.  He was a
people watcher.  Um, he was, um
, you know, Dan Kennedy
says, you know, he
always talks about,
you know, marketing while
walking.
Ahem.
You know, Gene was doing
copywriting while
walking.
Um, yes.  You know, it's
essentially the same thing
because copywriting and
marketing are related,
but it's an important
aspect of
being a great
copywriter.
Yes.  No, really.  And that's
one of the reasons why I
find it so interesting
that today we're
talking about a person
who passed away
over 20, even 25
years ago.  A book
written 60 years ago
,
1966, is
100% relevant.  There is nothing in this book
that is not
relevant.  Let's
talk about this for a
second.  Why is this
book so
timeless?  Why is she
so remarkable?  And why should
people in 2025,
especially the new
copywriters on my
list, people who
watch YouTube,
are immersed in it,
are interested in the world of
AI and new cool
offers in
internet marketing,
read it?  And
when you talk about a
book that's 60 years old,
they say, "Why would
I need to know that?"
Well, you know, they should
read "Science
Advertising," written back
in 1923.  So it's
not just about 1966.
The reason I laid out
in the afterword to
Titans Marketing
is that
human behavior hasn't
changed since 1966.    It has
n't changed, it
seems, since I wrote about
it in 1066.
So people remain
people.  And that's why the book talks
a lot about
copywriting.  There's a
lot about
copywriting,
marketing, markets,
how to create a
market, mass
desires, but especially
levels of awareness and
levels of complexity
are something that's
not just about marketing.
This is about human
behavior.  And the thing is,
he describes it
very richly, very
specifically in this
book.
Yes.
That's why the bootcamp is
so valuable, because you've
seen all the texts
we wrote earlier
at the bootcamp.  The book
is packed with information
, and because of that, you may
not want to tackle
it.  And if you do
take the plunge and
read it, you still
might not
understand how to
put it into
practice.  And there's no
point in spending
$125 on a book that
you'll only review and
not adapt for
your business.  And this is where
bootcamp comes to the rescue, because
it gives you that
opportunity.  You are
actually forced
to read it.  It's similar
to how when I was writing
my book "Overdeliver,"
one of the great
things was creating an
audio version.  You know,
I
had to read my book for two days
.
I got new ideas
for a book I just
wrote while
working on the
audio version.
You're like, "Brian, that's
good.  "That's really
good, Brian."
Yes.  But then Yes.
Then I said, “This is
bad.  I ruined it.
"  And we I tried to
make changes, but I couldn't
.  Um, well,
we were actually able to
make some changes at
that point.  Hmm,
small changes.  I could have
changed the words or
something, but then you
read “Breakthrough Advertising
” and you go, “Oh my God, this is
so profound.  I How do I
adapt this?  How should
I approach using it
?  And that
was the challenge that
Chris and I
faced, um, to
create a bootcamp, how
can we make it
useful, how can we make
it, that's what I'm
trying to do with
my workshop.  I
try to
use AI to
create
intensive summaries with
practical advice
from each
guest speaker.
This This, I may
not succeed, but I'm
trying.  I work with
Max Bernstein,
who is a good
copywriter who is
skilled in AI.  I'm not
good at AI.  I know
what AI can and ca
n't do.  But I, um, and he,
I was actually just
thinking about this today
, because I just
edited the first
resume with
AI, and you know, it's not good enough
yet,
because we want to make
it a paid subscription
on Substack as an entry into the Titans
Accelerator.  So, it's
similar to how Breakthrough
Advertising Boot Camp is an entrance
to Titans Accelerator.  This
Substack subscription is
like a light
version of Titans Accelerator
because it's a summary of
calls, but they
have to be actionable.  And
so, Breakthrough Advertising Boot
Camp was a way
to make Breakthrough Advertising
practical.  And then,
of course, that spawned
Breakthrough Advertising Mastery,
which is also worth
buying, but they don't
have to buy
it to be in the
bootcamp.  But Breakthrough
Advertising Mastery was,
basically, and it was a
happy accident.
Young k...why am I
paying attention to
young copywriters
, and you are now included.
Um, do you know this
guy, um, uh, Luis
Flavio?  Luis Luis,
Flav he has three
names, Luis Flavio, whatever
comes to mind.  So
he sends me an
email and
he said...again
, a young
copywriter from
Brazil, um, knows
Gene Schwartz.  He is
probably around 28 years old.
Sends me an email.
I mean, these are the
best letters I
get, you know?
It's like a 28-year-old
guy studying
Gene Schwartz.  This
guy, I adore
this guy, you
know.
Oh, you're already in high esteem.
You too.  You too.
I appreciate it.  I appreciate it.
I didn't know you,
you know, but Chris
said, "I have a
guy who would be
perfect for you."  He's in his
thirties
and a Gene
Schwartz fan.  I said, "I'll
talk to him,"
you know.
Yes.  Yes.  I
like it.
So, Luis, Luis
Flavio Nunez,
sends me
a proposal to do
something for the 55th anniversary of "
Breakthrough Advertising,"
whatever year it is
.  I can't
count.  '66, 55
years later, so it's
pretty recent.
Yes.  Yes.  2010, 2015, something
like that.
That's right.  And he says he
has, um, what's
that, 16,000?  Files with
advertising examples.  Over
time, he collected
examples from direct
mail,
emails, and more.  And
he says, "I've collected
every ad that
Gene mentions in '
Breakthrough Advertising.'"
I have ads,
for example,
corset ads in magazines from the
1950s.  "And
because Gene
was making arguments in
all these ads,
and you know, he
mentions them in '
Breakthrough Advertising,' he
usually
uses a
headline or something
like that."  He went and
got every
ad.  So I
said to him, "Dude,
what can we do about this
?"  That's cool.
This is like the best database of
advertising examples.  This is the
base of examples for '
Breakthrough Advertising.'
And then the bootcamp, we've
done a few
bootcamps. And
Chris and I, Chris, it was
Chris's idea more
than mine. He said, "
Let's put this all together
."  I said, 'Let's
use these
examples from Louis in
some book or
special report
or something.'"  And then
we said, "Why don't we
take the workbooks from
the bootcamp, put
them in a book, and then
add all
the ads as the second
part of the book," and that's how
"
Mastery of
Breakthrough Advertising" came about, and
"...
that became a supplementary
volume. Um, we sell
it for $75, I think it's $
digitally. Um
, we don't sell "
Breakthrough Advertising"
digitally,
but we sell "
Mastery of
Breakthrough Advertising." And it's
pretty
dense.
It's 500 pages. Damn it
.
This thing, this thing is
thick and
oh, we ship it
to Australia. People
are shocked at how much it
costs to ship.
Yeah. Well, because it
weighs three or four
pounds, or whatever.
And all the ads --
at the end.
All the ads. Which is
incredible.
Incredible.
It was, you know, one thing
complemented the other. Um,
and it's interesting, you know,
Gene's wife,
Barbara, when I
send her a
royalty check every  half a year
. She says, "I don't
understand."  Why is Gene
so much more
popular now than
when he was alive?  "
But we did a good
job, you know, of
spreading his name.
He was legendary,
somewhere in the ether. The
book
was basically almost
impossible to
buy for a long time. And you know,
um, you know, to bring
it back, to be a conduit
for Gene
Schwartz's work—that's one of,
you know, definitely
one of the
highlights of
my career
. I love it.
I'm thrilled. I think it's
important. And honestly
, to Barbara's point,
why is Gene Schwartz
more important, or more
important, more
popular now
than he was then? I
love that he's
become more popular, because
frankly, that's
one of the reasons I
wanted to have this
conversation. I think
we need it now
more than ever.
I think
you need to
learn some
fundamental things.
You can
use AI
as much as you want. It's
great. I love AI. I
love, I love ChatGPT. I
love, I love Claude. I
love all of that.
But
it does
n't work very well on a bed of sand.  Okay. On a
foundation of
fundamental
eternal truths.
It's going to be better. Everything is
better when there's a foundation.
Everything is better when it's
served on a foundation of
fundamental
knowledge. Everything is better when it's
served on a foundation of, with, with,
with, with a foundation.
You know, like in
health food stores
, you take the foundation and
then you take the protein and there's this
foundation of eternal truths.
Yeah. No, absolutely. And
frankly,
fundamentals to me, when
I think of breakthrough
advertising, I think of
fundamentals on steroids.
It's the most modern
way to look at
fundamentals. You mentioned that
it's hard to
digest. It
really is hard. I
barely got through the first
three chapters when I
first bought it.
That's why Paris
Andropolis talks
about
using it with
his
copywriting students that
he trains. He says,
you know, you and this you could
use,
I think we
used this in
part of the
bootcamp copy. Basically
, it's, uh, he said, and
I  I do this when you
buy a book from me. There's a
note that comes with the book that says,
"Read the first
three chapters three times
before you move on
to the rest of the book." So
you can absorb it.
You'll get
a lot more out of the
rest of the book. That's how
Paris teaches it to
his copywriters.
He also says, you know,
when I ask Paris,
"Isn't 'Breakthrough
Advertising' the
most important book
on copywriting and
marketing?"  ", he says
it might be
the most important, but it's
not the first one to
read.
You know, Paris—it's not...
he's really the first one to
really talk
about it as an
advanced textbook on
marketing and
copywriting. And so
that doesn't mean it should
n't be in
your library.
It should be in the
library of every
copywriter and
marketer. But don't
read it before
you've read "The Scientific
Advertising." Don't read
it before you
've read, you know, "
Ogilvy on Advertising."
Don't even read it
before
you've read
Collier's book on
sales letters. Although it's
also quite dry and
complicated. Uh. Yeah.
Yeah. It's 1910s,
1920s for it.
Yeah. I mean, I
don't know if it's that
old. Maybe 1940s,
but it's old. It's
old. Uh, yeah, that's why
my first book
with Craig  Simpson, "The
Advertising Solution,"
that's why I
was drawn to this book.
Chris, uh, Craig
did a lot of the
prep
work on this
book, the hard
part at the beginning. And
he came to me, "
Do you want to
co-author this
book with me?"  "And I didn't
know if I wanted to or not. And
I said yes. When I
saw what the
book was, it actually
took six
advertising legends who were,
uh, they were like,
'Mad Men.'
You know, '
Mad Men?'
Oh, sure. Yeah. You
even talk about
Mad Men-style marketing in
Overdeliver, where you say
it's a completely different
concept than direct
response. The complete
opposite.
Right.
Exactly. Uh, but
basically they
were all the same '
mad men,' but they
were trapped, because
they were actually
direct response marketers,
but they were caught up in
general
advertising, because
direct marketing did
n't exist back then.
But man, what
was scientific about
advertising in 1923? Well,
Claude Hopkins knew.
Yeah.
David Ogilvy knew it in the '
60s.
Schwartz knew it in the '60s.  Um
, you know, that basically
gave birth to all the
direct
response divisions, like Ogilvy & Mather
Direct, BBDO, all the big
agencies
on Madison Avenue, all the
agencies from
Mad Men
started
direct marketing divisions.
Mather Direct, BBDO Direct, Wonderman
Direct—all of that was
happening
early in my
marketing career in the '80s. Those
were the most popular
agencies. They
were doing direct
response within the
general advertising
agencies. So it
wasn't just
general advertising anymore. It
was direct response. And
those six legends that
Craig wrote about,
Gene was one of them.
So it was obvious to me
to be a
part of this book,
but Gene Schwartz and Gary
Galbert were two of
them. And the other four
were people
you might not have heard of.
Even today's
copywriters have heard of
Gary Galbert and
Gene Schwartz if
they're
trying to achieve anything. But
they might not have heard of—and they should have
—
David Ogilvy.  They
might not have heard of
John Caples, who
was, you know, the leading
expert on
testing, um, and the
author of the book on the
Collier letters.
um
um, Claude Hopkins and
his "Scientific
Advertising," so these
six legends, and we
were able to summarize the
best of
these
six legends.
It didn't work with Gene,
because "Breakthrough Advertising
" was too
complex. You could
use this—I
never
used this
text in bootcamp, but you
can do something with it
. Maybe
say that Brian
wrote "The Advertising
Solution," covering the
six legends of advertising.
You could
list them. Um, and
then say that
Gene was one of them.
And Brian always felt
that he couldn't do
Gene's work justice
because "Breakthrough
Advertising" was so
rich and so, um,
transformative.
Yeah.
That it needed
something more. And
so when he
republished "Breakthrough
Advertising," it
needed something more.
And it became  bootcamp.
It became a
masterclass in "Breakthrough
Advertising." Um, so you
can, it gives you a
kind of, you're essentially
drawing on David
Ogilvy, Claude
Hopkins, Robert
Collier, even Gary
Galbert. Gary
Galbert never
wrote a real
book. He had "The
Gary Galbert Letter,"
the legendary "The
Gary Galbert Letter." "
Letters from the Harrow."
Oh, "Letters from the Harrow."
Yeah, it's, yeah, they were
letters. But it's an
important book, isn't
it?
Oh. Oh, you mean
his newsletter, like
his actual, like,
letter.
It's basically, if you
take his newsletters and
just put them
together, one of the
greatest copywriting books ever
written
.
Actually, there's a funny
story about that. I
paid a guy
$200 on Upwork to
compile them chronologically for me in a
Word document. I
think so. I mean,
I don't know why
Kevin and Bond never
did it.
Well, somebody did.
It's been online
for a while because I
asked, I think I
tweeted about it or
something. It's not in the
public domain
. They, Kevin and Kevin
and Bond, are very
productive.
Oh, [ __ ]. I might have
noticed. Sorry,
guys. Well, they're
free on the
internet, so I
thought, "Hey, can
someone..."
Yeah, but they could
do more with it.
I mean, you know
, I... I... uh...
Yeah, it's
... it's... it's really
funny. But they're
legends. They're legends,
that's obvious. So, I
know a lot of people
know Halpert. You're
right. Cable is probably
a little out of the loop. Um,
yeah...
Collier is definitely out of
the loop. Hopkins is not
out of the loop in
traditional
copywriting
circles, like
if you're an AWAI copywriter
, because Clayton
Makepeace  did
everyone a great, great
service by highlighting
these guys. Uh,
did it every
chance he got, and he was the
keynote speaker at
AWAI for
years, and there are a lot of
AWAI alumni there. Some
of them aren't very good
copywriters, but
at least they
graduated from AWAI, but
you know, Clayton
gets credit for
that. Clayton.
Yeah.
Uh, even more
than Deutsch, than Paris,
than a lot of the other
guys of that
generation, my
generation, really. Um
, I always give
Clayton the most
credit because he
just wanted to teach.
He wanted to be, he
was a professor
of copywriting. But I
honestly think
Clayton Makepeace is
one of the most
underrated. I think
he's underrated in the
circles I'm in right now
because
most people don't
know about Quick Start.
No. No. And he, you know,
he just passed away in
2020, you know. Um, but I
...I'm going to... it's
funny when I re...
but I'll tell you, it's
good, it's good
news that he's
unknown or
famous. One of my
blogs, I blog.
When he died, I
did, I did a
podcast
tribute, um, blog for
him. I've done
it a few times since
2020; I haven't
done it in a while. And Chris
does, Chris has,
I, we have two
Filipino, um,
virtual
assistants who
take, uh, snippets of
my blog posts
and post them on
LinkedIn, X, Facebook, and one.
The one that got
the most responses,
the most
engagement out of all the ones
that we put out. Not
that they
got that
many, but for LinkedIn,
it was quite a lot
. Um, that was my
piece on
Clayton Makepeace.
Really?
Yeah. People who know
who he is, they
react the same way
you do. How can you not
mention this
guy almost  on the
same level? Not
exactly, but like
Galbert, Schwartz, Ben
Swina and Rutz, he's,
he's almost on the same
level.
Well, as far as
teaching
copywriting.
Yes, definitely.
In that sense, "
quick start," when
someone asks me,
because a lot of people say, "
Okay, where do I start,
and so on?"  And besides, like
Joe Sugarman, AdWeek, the
copywriting guide, right?
Claude Hopkins, "The
Scientific Advertising."
Besides those,
in your, in one of
your YouTube videos, you
mentioned two other
books besides Sugarman that
I'm not that
familiar with, but
if they're...
I had a book by
Bob Bly that I found
useful if you...
What is it? "The
Copywriter's Guide." "The
Copywriter's Guide
." I keep it as something to
pull off
the shelf if you need to
look at something, because
it's a very versatile
book, where he
talks about
Meta advertising and
landing pages.
No, and Bob Bly is also
one of the great
teachers. He
really, you know,
makes the point that you don't
have to be a
practitioner to
teach. He's a good
copywriter. He
was never a
major star
in the days of Bill Jamie
, Jim Rutz, and Ben
Swina. Bob Bly was a
step down. I,  I, I
tested him a few
times in the Boardroom. He
just didn't have that
spark
, but he's an amazing,
amazing teacher of the
craft.
Oh yeah. Yeah.
Tommy Lord, I don't know
baseball. Tommy Lord
was one of the
worst
baseball players of all
time, and he became a
Hall of
Fame manager. So you can
do it. You can
do it.
Yeah. I mean,
again, kudos to
those guys, even as
I said,
Clayton Makepeace
is one of the
best teachers to me,
because when I read
his "Quick Start to
Copywriting," I
thought, "Where was that
before? That's everything I was
looking for."
Yeah, he was
special.
Yeah, it was just
incredible. But
back to Gene,
I read one
page of "Breakthrough
Advertising." He writes
this line: you can't
create
desire. You have to
channel mass
desire. Yeah. Exactly.
And then I close...
don't create desire.
Yeah. I  I close
the book and I think, how do
I do this?
Yeah.
It's just like...
the desire is already there in
the market. The job
of a copywriter is to
know, to find it,
to put it together. You
don't have to
invent it.
No. No. And then he goes
on and talks about how the
text
is made up of parts,
and it goes back to what's
not in the book and
all that.
That's right. That's what he
meant when he
said the text
is put together, right?
Yeah. And I'm like, "[ __ ] you
." I'm sitting here
trying to think of
the best headlines
or something, and they're like,
"No, man."
Just look
around for a minute.
Dig in, dive in
. That's why bootcamp is
so relevant, because you
get that phrase.
And I was sitting there thinking, I don't
know what to do with this.
I don't even know how to
use this. I
don't even understand how to
understand this.
Yeah. But that's also why
bootcamp—if
you go back to it
—so powerful
because of the
worksheets that we've
put together. The exercises
that we do are
applicable to all
businesses, all
categories. And that's that
extra boost
that you need.
So you've read
something in "Breakthrough
Advertising." How do I
apply it to
my business? And that's why
I know you'll write a
good copy for
your bootcamp. You
can borrow
anything you want from
what we have.
We have a lot of everything.
Hopefully, Chris
sent you all of the...
He sent it. He
sent me a bunch of
stuff.
Okay. So you can
adapt,
use it or
not, but I would definitely
advise you to connect
, you know, theory with
practice. And practice
is, you know,
homework within
the bootcamp. If you don't
want to, you can't
.
We won't
check
attendance. But,
you know, if you
don't, you won't
get as much out
of the bootcamp
because with the
hot
seat feature, we can
dissect your
specific business and
how to apply
concepts from Breakthrough
Advertising. Isn't that
great?
Yeah, it's simple, it's
just incredible.
Two weeks, six
calls, you know.
Yeah, that's... Do we have a
bootcamp date yet? I
know, Chris was
We have two weeks. We have
these two weeks. That's
going to be
When are these two weeks?
Yeah, we'll
get a schedule soon. It's going to be
the weeks of October 20th and 27th
. Um,
usually the first
week is Tuesday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday
or Tuesday,
Thursday, Friday, and the
second week is
usually, maybe
Monday, Wednesday,
Thursday, something like that.
Yeah. What I, what I think is
crazy, again
, price, six
calls, we're
discussing
the most legendary
book, on the
fundamentals, advanced
fundamentals. Will you be on
the call? Brian,
will you be on these calls
?
Yeah.
You'll be on these
calls. This and this 297.
This will be easy
to write.
Yeah.
But I... I
need  will be in a
few minutes. So
tell me what
we didn't talk about, what
you really wanted for
your copy,
based on the
questions you
sent in?
Honestly, I think
we covered pretty much
everything I wanted to
make sure we
covered. I
mean, number seven,
you know, why
should copywriters
join
our bootcamp? And it's
not just copywriters,
you know, it's
marketers. It's
anyone in business
who wants to sell
more, promote
more. Um, you
know,
you should at least...
you don't have to
write everything yourself. There
will be people on the call
that you can
hire to
write for you, but that's
not the hardest part.
The hardest part is for you,
as an entrepreneur, as a
business owner, to
figure out your
market, how to approach
your market, how to, you
know, not
create desire, but
how to gather that desire
together. Um, and you know,
put together your copy. And
you don't have to
put it together
yourself,
using
working  sheets in
the bootcamp. It will be
put together for you.
If you don't want to
write it yourself, you
can use
ChatGPT to create a
first draft based on the
handouts that you
get during the
bootcamp.
That will be the first
step to writing
your first
pitch.
Yeah, it's a huge,
huge
step. Especially because
a lot of the
handouts in the
bootcamp, I know, Chris
has them in Google
Sheets or Excel formats that
you can just
download.
They're all available for
download. Yeah,
they're all... it's really
good, I mean,
we've done
eight of them. This will be our
ninth. So, uh...
and each one is
better than the last one.
That's another factor.
Each one is
better because it's a
cumulative
result of what
worked in the
previous ones, and we're
constantly adding to them and
improving them. Yeah
, that's true. I
mean, Chris
uses different
ads in each
bootcamp. He's
changed some of the
handouts a little bit and
integrated them with AI a little bit. You
know, it's not easy...
and that's another point.
Don't think,  that if
the book was written in
1966, everything in it is
100% relevant
today, but we're
going to show you how to
adapt AI to
disruptive advertising.
Yeah.
Not to copy everything
,
you know. Not to just
copy. But to
adapt,
to evolve your
thinking and move
forward, but you
still have to
do the work.
Yeah. Yeah. It's a strategy
, an approach, a mindset,
right,
what's behind it, right? The
technical work,
the execution of tasks
changes over time,
but what he laid out
as the basis of the approach
is absolutely timeless,
right? And we also
made it
practical. So it's both
timeless and
practical. I
like it.
I'm excited. Brian, is there
anything else you...
No, we've covered everything we've
planned. We've been
jumping around a bit
.
I like it.
I tend to
get off topic,
so we've gotten a little off
topic.
Sorry.
No, honestly, I'm not going to go into that.
I was hoping.
Of course, this isn't the first time I've listened to you
. I've listened to
you from afar on Titans,
you've interviewed
Ben and so many other things
. So I thought, "Oh, this is
going to be interesting." I do
n't even think we're
going to get to
all the questions, and that's
totally fine. and
we're going to have a great
time. Um, but honestly
, the last
announcement, of course, is this
video you're watching right now
on my
YouTube, and it's
coming out soon. My
mailing list will know
about it. So you're going
to get
a bunch of emails from me about it. I'm going to be a
part of it.
I'm going to be there. Brian's going to be
there. Chris Mason's
going to be there. It's
incredibly important. I
think this is one of the
most fruitful
times for
us to be able to
do this. One of the
most fruitful
proposals,
at least in 2025. I'm
grateful that you're still
doing this. So I want to
take this
opportunity and I'm
going to write
a bunch of
commercials. Anything you want
to say to our
guys before
I say this.  What? We're not
looking for people to
promote our
bootcamp.
You came to us on your
own.
That's right.
So basically it's like... you
don't choose your
mentors, your
mentors choose
you. You don't choose your salespeople
. Your salespeople
choose you. So you
chose us, and that
made it pretty
clear that we
want you to
do this for us. We're
not looking for a bunch of
partners. We don't
play
affiliate games.
You know, people keep
saying I'm losing
money. I'm
fine with that. I don't live
for money. I live
for influence and
education and all
that. But when a
young copywriter
comes knocking on our door,
we have to
make sure they're
real. You
look real
. So you're obviously
genuine. You're definitely
on your way to great
success. So
no cons for us. All pros
.
All pros for
you, because there's not going to be
many people.
Bob Lai seems to be pushing
this too,  by the way. But that's it
.
I'll try to get around Bob
Yeah, that's it. Another
thing I would say, I was
just thinking about all
my digressions and
so on. One of the
things you could
add without
making it
negative—it's, you
know, hard to do
, but you could say, I
had a conversation with Brian
just to
discuss the bootcamp,
to get his perspective so that
I could really
understand everything before I
go through it and you
go through it.
Yeah. You, you know,
got access to the
whole bootcamp
for free,
obviously. But, but
then, um,
you basically say something
like, Brian always
says that he's a
complete digression
just
waiting to happen.
Man, I felt it! And,
you know what? It was hard to
bring him back to
the topic of
Gene and Breakthrough
Advertising. But the
knowledge that he
gave me and the way he
came back to
Breakthrough Advertising—he did
n't just go away
from  topics down a
rabbit hole to the moon
. He went—if there
's a rabbit hole to the moon
—he went into a digression,
but he came back,
because everything revolves
around the original source
, around the fundamentals,
around the eternal truths.
So we talked about
Clayton Makepeace. We
talked about Paris
Lampropoulos. We
talked about, you know,
um, the bullies, the
obsessions, and the things
that Gene went through and
Paris is doing now.
Or you can add
all that and say,
I think Brian will be the same
on the
calls. So
I hope you're ready
for sudden
digressions
that can lead
to incredible
insights, or you're
just going to go crazy
with these digressions.
But anyway,
you can make it
a little, you know, a little
self-deprecating about
me if you want. I
don't mind
that. But
turn it into a
positive: they
get 44 years of my
experience, everything I
can share about
Gene, Breakthrough Advertising,
and all  retreats for
six calls.
Yeah, I definitely...
maybe there's something
for you. I don't know.
Maybe there's something
for you.
It's, uh, "Bensettlism"
- making a skeleton
dance
with your
bullets. He always
says, don't hide a
skeleton in the closet.
Wave it at
them and
use it to
sell. I'll find a
way to
beat that, and it'll be
fun. But I'm really, really excited
. Again,
I think it's
incredibly important
to be in people's eyes these days.
So, I'm happy to be on
these calls, to
communicate, to
share this with
people, and to spend
more time listening to
retreats, because we're
coming back.
No problem.
Oh, that's a
given when you're on
my line. So,
well, great. I
really want to
appreciate your time. I
know you need to
go. Um, I appreciate
even taking the
time to do it.
It really means a lot
to me. It
really does. So
thank you,  Brian. I'll
write you an
email and
we'll agree on when it
can be launched,
when I send the emails,
just so we're on the
same page, because I want to. Yeah,
of course, I mean
Chris will
be doing most of that
, but I can
be on top of the
correspondence, yeah, I'll I'll
send that to Chris.
Yeah, I don't know what
your Colby score is, but
mine is 5393, where a three is a
sequence.
Yeah,
my nine is a
quick start. So,
yeah. Um, you don't have to
rely on me for
the details. I mean, I
know the details and I can
pass them on to you, but you
have to rely
on Chris for that. But
keep me in the loop
. You can cc
me on
anything.
And I'll chime in if
I feel like I have something to
add. Great. Yeah, I'll
coordinate everything with Chris.
I just want to be
sure about the
timelines for the promotion
and things like that.
That's all on Chris.
Well, we
We'll talk it over with him, and
then
he'll make the decision.
Karla needs to
be kept informed too, because
she's in charge of my
schedule. So, but it's
more up to Chris and
Karla. So, it's not you.
That's fine.
Don't worry. I'll
take care of it. We'll
do it, and then I'll
send out all
the materials, as I'll
get you a
lot of participants.
How big is
your list?
Well, it's almost 4,000 now.
Almost 4,000.
Great.
Which again, it is
. I definitely
follow
Ben Settle's approach of "small
but mighty list."
Yeah, mine is like that too.
Although mine don't buy,
usually.
Oh, seriously? I
mean, they'll buy a
bootcamp or something
, but I've pretty much
weaned them off of buying
because my blog is
all
postscripts. I do
n't, I don't, I'm
uncomfortable, you know,
and I do, I do what I
want, you know, it's
my blog. I can
do whatever I want with it
. But, I
mean, we were selling,
we, we did it a little bit
. We kind of did a
launch for Titans Accelerator,
you know, a series of
emails. I
, I rarely do it. I
do it every now and then,
but it's like, like
Joe Polish says, I'm the director
of
sales prevention, and you know,
uh, sometimes, but I,
I'm fine with it. I
wear it as a badge of
honor because I, I, I,
I'm all about
value and content first. And
I don't recommend it to
everyone. I mean,
you know, Ben's style is
so effective and
so powerful. Your
style is your style.
He, he's obviously
effective. Um,
you know, you have to, you have to be
yourself. But my, my
list, you know, they
don't, they don't, they
just don't, I
try to... You
think I should be
selling
Titans Accelerator memberships directly
through my
mailing list, and I don't
.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's
fine. I
mean, again,
every…it
took me a while to
figure out how, well, am
I doing this right?
Am I doing this
wrong? There’s no
right or
wrong.
Yeah. I mean, from a
metrics perspective, I
always think, can
I do a big
launch?
That’s true. That’s true.
Um, but in
launches,
we usually have a lot of fun
because… Right. I
mean, you learn along
the way, you know,
add bonuses.
Yeah, I learned a lot
from launches.
That’s right. Absolutely.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
yeah. I mean,
you have a lot more
knowledge in this than
I do. That’s right. Knowledge
, not tons,
tons of
direct
experience, but I’ve done
a few launches, but, you
know, everything I’ve
done in my career
has been some kind of
launch. You know, it’s
like,
you know, doing a
million-unit direct mail campaign, it’s a
launch.
You see, you’re vastly
overqualified
for
Jeff Walker's mastermind. I don't I
could, I can
justify it, whether they'll
buy into that
argument...I don't know
.
I'll take it. I'll have a
lot of fun with
it. Okay, great,
push it.
Amazing. Amazing.
Brian, if there's anything I can do to
help,
just get in touch.
Okay, great. Allan,
thank you, Brian. I
appreciate it.
See you
later. Bye.